alors j'ouvre tout de suite dans ce sens
public notre second débat il est
consacré au partage des richesses
vendredi les partenaires sociaux valider
un accord pour déployer l'intéressement
et la participation dans les entreprises
de moins de 50 salariés on va en
débattre dans un instant mais d'abord un
gros plan sur les sociétés qui vont
encore plus loin le 5 janvier dernier le
Crédit Mutuel et la MAIF font annoncée
reverser une part importante de leur
bénéfice à des projets environnementaux
ou solidaires et c'est le cas aussi de
ce cabinet de conseils dans lequel nous
sommes allés en reportage qui lui
reverse ces dividendes à des
associations Audrey Vittaz
depuis deux ans François Hubert est
consultant dans un cabinet un peu
particulier ici on conseille les
entreprises pour favoriser l'égalité des
chances
pour lesquels je suis arrivé chez
Tenzing sachant que mon parcours avant
était dans des cabinets un peu plus
classiques et c'est vrai que je
retrouvais pas cette notion de sens que
je retrouve là et qui me plaît beaucoup
mais ce qui fait surtout la fierté des
employés
ses créations il y a 6 ans Tensing
conseil tente l'inimaginable dans le
monde du capitalisme on a décidé de
faire en sorte que les associés du
cabinet renoncent leur dividende tous
les dividendes de l'entreprise sont
reversés à des associations qui luttent
contre les déterminisme social donc
depuis six ans on a redistribué 750 000
euros à une quinzaine d'associations
c'est ce qu'on appelle le dividende
sociétal et pour ce patron tout le monde
pourrait s'y mettre même au sommet du
CAC 40
25% de nos bénéfices si simplement
chaque entreprise distribue entre 5 et
10% on peut pas dire qu'en distribuant 5
et 10% des bénéfices ça changerait la
vie des actionnaires ce n'est pas
possible de dire ça en revanche quand
vous généraliser ça l'ensemble des
entreprises ça donnerait des milliards
d'euros des milliards d'euros qui
pourraient donc changer la vie des gens
mais avant cela il faut changer une
manière de penser l'entreprise qui date
des années 70 entreprises elle était là
pour dégager du bénéfice et finalement
c'est l'impôt qui consistait à à dire
que l'entreprise participe à la Nation
par l'impôt sauf que vous pouvez payer
beaucoup d'impôts en maltraitant vos
salariés et en polluant mais beaucoup le
concept chez Tenzing ils ont une chance
leur société à toujours pratiqué le
dividende société
le changement pourrait prendre du temps
il faut déjà que tout les directeurs les
associés se mettent d'accord dans les
entreprises pour pouvoir le faire
changer faire pivoter une organisation
qui est d'une certaine taille
effectivement pour moi c'est c'est très
différent en fait intérêt à le faire
parce que on peut pas gagner dans un
monde qui perd quoi la législation
pourrait aussi aider d'ici 2024 une
réglementation européenne imposera aux
entreprises de plus de 250 employés de
publier leur impact sur la planète et
les hommes
comment mieux partager la valeur créée
par les entreprises voilà la question
centrale de notre débat avec Nicolas
Terry bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes
président du Crédit Mutuel alliance
fédéral Cécile duflots bonsoir bienvenue
à vous aussi directrice générale d'Oxfam
France Jean Pisani ferry bonsoir
bienvenue vous êtes économiste
professeur à Sciences Po ancien
corradateur du programme économique
d'Emmanuel Macron il y a quelques il y a
quelques mois Émilie zappalski bonsoir
spécialiste en communication politique
et éditorialiste pour sciences publiques
on va commencer donc sur ce dividende
sociétal Nicolas Terry vous avez annoncé
le 5 janvier dernier la mise en place de
de ce dispositif vous allez redistribuer
chaque année 15% de votre résultat net
de vos bénéfices ça représente combien
d'argent cette année et surtout pourquoi
pourquoi vous avez pris cette décision
ça représente 525 millions cette année
et on a pris cette décision parce que
comme la très bien dit une intervenante
tout à l'heure on peut pas être prospère
dans un monde qui perd et donc la
transformation
environnementale la transformation
solidaire ça nécessite du capital ça
nécessite des moyens et le choix de
Crédit Mutuel est lancé fédéral c'est de
se donner les moyens de sa
transformation là et dans des
proportions qui sont significatives 15%
du résultat 500 millions je sais que
j'en payais le besoin d'investissement
il nous le dira probablement aux
alentours de 70 milliards vous voyez
pour la transformation environnementale
environnementale donc vous voyez que
s'il y a 180 entreprises qui font comme
nous et bien on couvre la facture et je
pense que son on a plus le temps en fait
ce qui est très intéressant c'est que on
procrastine depuis une 30 ans
le GIEC fonctionne très bien depuis 30
ans et on a perdu ce temps-là à faire le
truc et aujourd'hui bien la décision qui
a été prise d'ailleurs à l'unanimité par
nos élus mutualistes et par les
représentants des salariés c'est oui
nous sommes efficaces opérationnellement
mais oui aussi on veut que ça soit utile
collectivement alors j'avais animé la
conférence de lancement de ce dividende
de la société et c'est d'ailleurs ce qui
m'a donné l'idée l'envie de se débat ces
sites du flow vous y participiez et
alors ce qui est intéressant Oxfam qui
est depuis longtemps en première ligne
sur cette question de de la
redistribution de la richesse ou salut
l'initiative pourquoi vous la saluez on
a salu parce qu'on est convaincu que si
on veut tenir
nos objectifs de l'accord de Paris ce
qui est très compliqué il faut que
l'ensemble des acteurs s'allument il
faut que les politiques publiques et le
gouvernement soit beaucoup plus
volontariste mais il faut aussi que
l'ensemble des entreprises et peut-être
au premier rang desquels les banques
soit en situation de faire beaucoup
d'efforts parce qu'aujourd'hui si on
regarde le modèle économique actuel des
entreprises du CAC 40 on est un scénario
à plus trois degrés et demi si on
regarde les banques françaises on est à
plus qu'à degrés donc il faut absolument
changer structurellement la production
mais aussi se dire qu'on peut consacrer
une grosse partie de ces dividendes à la
transformation de son entreprise elle a
transformation de son environnement et
les banques c'est important je savais
que vous par le levier de
l'investissement tout enfin pas
seulement mais notamment par le levier
les trois plus grandes banques
françaises ont chacune prise à elle
seule plus d'impact sur le changement
climatique plus d'émissions de gaz à
effet de serre que le territoire
français donc évidemment quels sont
lessives c'est l'endroit où on ouvre on
ferme le robinet donc selon qu'elle
choisisse des investissements qui
permettent la décarbonation de notre
économie ou qu'elle continue de
poursuivre un modèle qui nous emmène
droit dans le mur climatique elles ont
un décisif donc elles ont un rôle sur ce
qu'elles font leur travail au quotidien
et le Crédit Mutuel a déjà fait des
efforts aussi qu'on a salué comme
d'autres banques comme la Banque Postale
mais elles ont aussi une manière
d'utiliser leurs dividendes qui peut
être positive ou qui peut simplement
servir à croître les inégalités on le
voit on va au devant d'une année record
de distribution de dividendes en 2023
après une année record en 2022 on y
reviendra notamment sur le dans quel
projet par exemple sur les énergies
fossiles il faut continuer d'investir ou
pas et qu'elle soit vous faites en la
matière jean-physanie ferry vous êtes
effectivement chargé d'une évaluation
par la première ministre de ce coût de
la transfusion de l'environnementale
donc vous dites quoi 100 milliards par
an c'est ce qu'il faut je dis pour
l'instant et avec précaution 70
milliards d'accord en 2030
donc ça représente à peu près deux
points de PIB
c'est le montant de l'investissement qui
est nécessaire pourquoi parce que
cette transformation beaucoup de capital
ça va demander beaucoup de capital parce
que une bonne partie de ce qui doit être
fait c'est de changer les équipements
c'est de changer des chaudières c'est de
changer des voitures c'est de changer
des véhicules c'est d'équiper des
logements et des bâtiments
ça coûte du capital et donc tout ça
c'est nécessairement quelque chose qui
va peser en fait dans les années à venir
sur sur le bien-être collectif même si à
terme ça améliorera le bien alcoolitif
il y a une période transitoire il faut
pas se cacher qui va être une période
plus difficile ça commence par coûter de
l'argent avant d'en rapporter et même
au-delà
et puis avant de de qu'on envoie les
efforts
et comme on a attendu trop longtemps le
mur est devant nous et donc il faut il
faut il faut précipiter en fait l'action
si je peux me permettre mais ce que je
trouve ça aussi c'est que là vous parlez
beaucoup plus d'investissement que de
dépenses et de coûts même si le mot coup
est encore là c'est à dire qu'on conçoit
enfin peut-être la transition écologique
comme un investissement et on le voit
parler dividendes puisque finalement les
entreprises ou les banques quand elles
ont des dividendes et qu'elle est
réinvestissent c'est pour des nouveaux
modes de production ou faire évoluer
pour avoir un peu plus de richesse là on
se dit et bien on va investir dans la
transition écologique c'est vrai qu'on a
du mal encore parce que c'est loin la
trajectoire elle est loin de savoir ce
qu'on va y gagner il faudrait presque
qu'on y voit plus clair sur ça c'est à
dire quand on aura par exemple rénové
tous les bâtiments qui sont des
passoires thermiques dont on entend
parler beaucoup qu'est-ce que ça va
permettre comme économie pour les
particuliers pour les organismes les
bailleurs sociaux pour l'État
globalement qu'est-ce qu'on va gagner
quand on aura des modes de production
qui seront plus économes en énergie et
c'est tout ça on parle beaucoup plus
d'investissement on n'a pas encore le
retour sur investissement concret dans
nos têtes j'imagine que ça va venir mais
on a déjà franchi un pas de passer du
coup à l'investissement il me semble
Nicolas Terry on est très concret ça
veut dire que vous allez avec ces 25
c'est ça mignon d'euros vous allez par
exemple investir dans des entreprises
des startups sans leur donner de
l'impératif de rentabilité financière
pendant plusieurs années de longues
années c'est ça pendant le temps qu'il
faut c'est à dire que l'idée qu'on a eu
dans le dividende société c'est surtout
de couvrir tous les aspects c'est à dire
une moitié pour l'investissement 35%
pour la tarification solidaire parce que
moi je crois fondamentalement que la
révolution environnementale elle est
elle doit être solidaire parce que c'est
une révolution totalement inégalitaire
si vous mettez une tarification du
carbone et bien les plus riches à coups
de de de de millions éventuellement
pourront s'acheter un bien-être
environnemental mais qui sera contre la
collectivité et puis 15% de mécénat et
je pense qu'il faut vraiment aller
depuis l'investissement jusqu'au resto
du coeur j'ai envie de dire pour prendre
en compte tout le sujet alors il y a un
poids sur lesquels il faut être clair
nous n'aurons pas la même rentabilité
financière parce que vous voyez que
dont on parle c'est de mettre à la
poubelle un modèle de production qui est
carbonée qui est théoriquement rentable
sur le plan financier mais il faut se
dire c'est de la perte pure a constater
tout de suite donc ça veut dire que ça
vous fragilise pardon nous interrompre
par rapport à vos concurrents si on
reste sur des sur des
réflexions qui ce qui ne tiennent pas
compte de ce qu'on appelle l'extra
financier uniquement voilà du bilan
comptable à l'ancienne en quelque sorte
mais vous savez la banque c'est un
commerce des promesses
d'aujourd'hui on vend des crédits
immobiliers dont la dernière échéance
est en 2048 et donc si en 2048 ou en
2045 le logement n'a plus de valeur et
la personne n'a plus d'emplois parce que
le climat rend l'économie ingérable la
créance bancaire qui vous paraît très
rentable aujourd'hui désolé mais elle
vaut plus rien et donc à un moment donné
notre métier c'est d'aller voir loin
devant en se disant que tout ce qu'on
fait aujourd'hui et bien quand on
finance un investissement d'entreprise
horizon 7 ans ce qui est très courant ça
veut dire qu'on est déjà en 2030 quand
on fait un emprunt immobilier journée en
2048 et donc
l'idée c'est de se dire on met à la
poubelle en mode de production carbonée
qui ne convient plus et on fait émerger
très vite une nouvelle infrastructure un
nouveau mode de production peut-être
avec un taux de rendement du capital
beaucoup plus faible pour solvabiliser
beaucoup de projets et on assume de
faire émerger sa vie
le jour où vous annonciez allez-y je
vais je reprends la main juste après
honnête ce que vient d'être dit c'est
exactement ce que vous demande les
superviseurs ça veut dire quoi ça
superviseur les régulateurs c'est
d'ailleurs il demande aux banques de
prendre en compte le risque climatique
en disant et ça c'est un c'est
utile
même si c'est pas suffisant mais c'est
utile en disant prenez en compte le fait
que dans 10 ans dans 20 ans il y a un
certain nombre de risques qui sont liés
de risque de crédit de risque de
dévalorisation des actifs
qui sont liés à ce changement climatique
et qui sont essentiels donc ensuite à ça
vous rajoutez votre propre politique
et
ça pose pour être honnête
ça pose quelques questions parce que je
pense que votre propre politique
la vôtre est très bien par rapport à ces
objectifs mais il peut y en avoir
d'autres qui sont différentes
c'est-à-dire à ce moment on laisse ces
entreprises décider à quoi elles vont
consacrer leur dividendes sociétales il
peut y avoir d'autres types de
dividendes sociétales donc oui
d'ailleurs le jour vous annoncez le
vôtre la MAIF annonce un dividende
écologique en disant on consacre 10% de
nos bénéfices à un dividende
d'écologique donc c'est c'est proche
mais c'est un petit peu différent ça ça
c'est toujours dans les ça va dans le
bon sens mais ensuite il y a des il y a
des sociétés et qui peuvent consacrer un
dividende sociétal à autre chose
et qui va pas nécessairement dans le bon
sens donc
l'argument consistant à dire c'est pas
aux entreprises de décider c'est au
gouvernement c'est aux élus sur la base
de finalités qui ont été délibérés c'est
pas un argument qu'on peut écarter dans
leur domaine je pense que aujourd'hui ça
ne suffit pas le à montrer ses limites
on est obligé de la direction que dit
Nicolas mais cette c'est tout de même
c'est le raisonnement va pas de soi j'ai
emploie des grands mots c'est s'il lui
faut est-ce que c'est un nouveau
capitalisme que l'urgence
environnementale voilà nous oblige à
inventer en tout cas ce qu'il faut si on
fait un tout petit pas de côté je vous
ai entendu expliquer oui mais votre
rentabilité financière par rapport à
d'autres oui c'est vrai aujourd'hui les
entreprises pétrolières on l'a vu des
records et vont battre des records de
profits de distribution dividendes mais
c'est très court thermiste c'est-à-dire
à quel prix le prix c'est un monde à
trois degrés un monde à 4 degrés
c'est-à-dire un monde fracassé donc on
peut trouver sa rationnel je trouve ça
complètement absurde et je voudrais
aller dans le sens de ce que dit
Monsieur Pisani ferry en disant on peut
quand même se dire que et c'est ce que
propose aux femmes c'est d'abord qu'on
plafonne la distribution de dividendes
pour deux raisons pour permettre
d'investir par exemple il faudrait
plutôt que distribuer ces dividendes
assez actionnaires total ferait mieux
d'investir majoritairement et très très
largement dans le changement de son
modèle c'est à dire il faut plus de
nouveau de nouveaux projets pétrol ou
gazier c'est ce qu'a dit l'Agence
internationale de l'énergie il faut plus
forêt de nouveau puis il faut il faut
s'arrêter donc forcément une entreprise
dont l'activité c'est l'exploitation
pétrolière il faut qu'elle fasse autre
chose et elle est tout à fait capable de
le faire dans l'histoire les entreprises
elles ont toujours évolué Nokia ils ont
commencé par faire des bottes en
caoutchouc puis ils ont fait des
téléphones portables la question c'est
la rapidité de la transformation oui
mais comme on a beaucoup attendu comme
on a empêché en faisant beaucoup de
lobbying pour empêcher un certain nombre
de contraintes on a pris beaucoup de
retard et je redis le mur se rapproche à
la vitesse grand V parce qu'on a aussi
besoin de politique publique donc il
faut que les entreprises évoluent
évidemment qu'elles choisissent de de
réorienter leur stratégie et il faut
aussi pouvoir taxer les super profits et
les
faire du flow pour pouvoir mener des
politiques publiques qui vont dans le
sens de la transition écologique j'y
reviendrai mais sur la question du
rythme je suis d'accord avec vous sur
l'urgence mais d'urgence de la
transformation du modèle sans casse
sociale
la difficulté elle est là aussi et
comment voilà quelle réponse vous
apporter à ça je le dis la question
c'est que
y compris ceux qui sont salariés dans
ces entreprises ils ont des enfants ils
ont des petits enfants peut-être ils ont
pas envie de leur laisser un monde pas
en héritage dans les années qui viennent
qui va être traversé par des mégafeux
qui fait peut-être qu'on va devoir aller
plus vite encore que ce qu'on pense mais
je le dis après la pandémie on a été
capable de clouer les avions au sol de
fermer les écoles de passer des millions
de personnes en télétravail très
rapidement
et sans casse sociale notamment en
France parce qu'on a nationalisé les
salaires par le biais du chômage partiel
on l'aurait eu ce qui est très
intéressant c'est que justement
maintenant que il y en a qui ont pu
bénéficier de ce soutien et qui du coup
touche des profits tombés du ciel qui
reverse à la solidarité nationale mais
la question de penser cette transition
aujourd'hui personne ne dit qu'il y a
pas les moyens financiers parce que si
on le fait pas si on le fait pas disons
qu'on le fait pas qu'on investit pas
c'est 70 milliards ça va coûter beaucoup
plus cher c'est pour le coup tout le
monde est certain je comprends je
comprends l'idée d'un encadrement un
petit peu de ses dividendes et savoir
comment ils sont utilisés parce que vous
l'avez pas dit spécialement mais si
c'est pas à titre écologique ça peut
être sur d'autres objets qui seraient
pas du tout productifs voilà qui serait
pas intéressant pour la France c'est ce
qu'on entend mais c'est quand même bien
commun voilà
mais c'est quand même intéressant que ça
vienne des entreprises parce que
justement c'est vrai que pendant la
crise covid on a fait de l'écologie sans
le vouloir mais on a été soutenu à plein
pot c'était une subvention quand même
c'était une grosse perfusion qu'on a eu
de l'État pendant toute cette période
qui nous a permis en effet d'être plus
écologique sur sur nos pratiques
maintenant je trouve que c'est
intéressant que c'est les que ce soit
les entreprises qui se saisissent de ça
je prendrai un autre exemple même sur la
la constitution des produits on a des
boîtes comme L'Oréal ou des grosses
boîtes qui se disent bah je vais plus
pouvoir produire mes produits comme
comme avant parce que les consommateurs
ils en veulent plus ils veulent plus des
produits fait n'importe comment donc il
y a quand même cette idée de de liberté
fin de libéralisme pour se lancer dans
des investissements comme ça et
peut-être qu'à terme l'état pourra
encadrer mais pour l'instant l'État ne
donne pas tellement de signaux
d'impulsion de ce côté-là je trouve en
tout cas ou alors quand il fait une
hausse des taxes carburants ça crée les
gilets jaunes parce que c'est fait un
peu maladroitement et pas dans une
égalité de traitement pour tout ce qu'on
dit intervenir je vous laissais dire ce
que vous voulez mais je vous je rajoute
une question est-ce que c'est plus
facile quand on est vous êtes mutualiste
c'est-à-dire vous avez pas des
actionnaires qui sont guillemets à vide
qui sont derrière vous est-ce que c'est
plus facile quand on est mutualise de
prendre une décision comme la parce que
nous on a des sociétaires qui sont ils
ont la tête près du bonnet ils ont
raison ils défend l'intérêt des
sociétaires et ils ont considéré avec
l'intérêt des sociétaires c'était de
lutter contre le changement climatique
de garder un esprit de solidarité c'est
le fondement du mutualisme et je pense
que la clé de la Révolution
environnementale c'est de se dire tous
ensemble de se dire tout le monde parce
que c'est pas une question de cas social
c'est une question sociale fondamentale
et d'ailleurs ce qui est intéressant
c'est la Confédération européenne des
syndicats a fait une étude globale sur
l'Union européenne en 2007 en disant
voilà le changement climatique ça va
avoir tel impact sur l'industrie du
charbon en Pologne sur l'industrie
automobile sur l'industrie lourde et
voilà les moyens qu'on va se donner
confédération européenne et syndicale
2007 qu'est-ce qu'on a fait dans
l'intervalle en gros rien et je voudrais
dire une chose oui comme président du
Crédit Mutuel je suis très fier de
l'initiative mais je le dis honnêtement
j'ai aussi une part de tristesse c'est
que ce boulot là c'est aussi l'état
c'est aussi la puissance publique qui
doit le faire on doit avoir un cadre et
notamment un cadre réglementaire et un
cadre qui nous dit telle activité
d'autorisée telle autre et interdite on
n'a jamais vu sur l'autoroute des gens
achetaient le droit de revenus de rouler
à 200 km/h et bien au fond c'est de ça
dont on parle quand on parle de la taxe
carbone bah non on se dit sur
l'autoroute la bonne vitesse d'ailleurs
pour le climat c'est 110 et il faut la
mettre très vite en place parce que ça
sera plus simple alors on va continuer
c'est lié évidemment cette question de
la du partager richesse ou du partage de
la valeur en
en parlant de des salariés maintenant
évidemment en pleine crise du pouvoir
d'achat ça n'a pas échappé à Emmanuel
Macron cet enjeu du partage de la
richesse écoutez-le c'est peut-être au
printemps dernier 9 juin pour être
précis la meilleure réponse au pouvoir
d'achat c'est de continuer de créer des
emplois de permettre à des gens qui
n'ont pas d'emploi de mieux gagner leur
vie par le travail et pour celles et
ceux qui travaillent de mieux gagner
leur vie dans le travail c'est aussi
pourquoi dès cet été je veux pouvoir
faire voter une réforme sur laquelle je
me suis engagé celle du dividende
salarié c'est-à-dire d'un meilleur
partage de la richesse alors depuis les
partenaires sociaux ont lancé des
négociations sur ce thème quand tu as
calmé vous pouvez nous nous rejoindre le
dividende salarié le partage de la
valeur en entreprise un accord qui a été
annoncé vendredi dernier voilà cela
faisait trois mois que les partenaires
sociaux travaillaient effectivement
dessus l'idée est d'étendre les
dispositifs tels que la participation
l'intéressement ou encore les primes de
partage de la valeur qui sont des
dispositifs de primes lorsque
l'entreprise réalise de bonnes
performances il s'avère qu'en France 50%
des salariés du privé touchent un de ses
avantages souvent parce qu'ils
travaillent dans de grands groupes
l'idée donc d'élargir les possibilités
de les mettre en place l'accord prévoit
un cycle des entreprises entre 11 et 49
salariés et qui sont rentables depuis au
moins trois années consécutives devront
mettre en place l'un des trois
dispositifs de partager la valeur
écouter Geoffroy route des yeux le
patron des patrons qui s'est félicité de
l'accord signé dans une courte vidéo
nous avons montré que nous sommes
capables ensemble de bâtir des compromis
pour mieux associer les salariés à la
création de valeur dans nos entreprises
c'est la preuve concrète d'une maturité
des partenaires sociaux alors nous
sommes pas d'accord sur tout avec les
syndicats sont pas d'accord sur la
réforme des retraites soit mais nous
pouvons discuter nous entendre sur
d'autres sujets nous faisons la preuve
que la démocratie sociale fonctionne au
moment où la démocratie parlementaire ne
donne pas le meilleur des exemples
l'accord vise également les super
profits alors certes de façon très
modeste mais en cas de résultat
exceptionnels les entreprises de plus de
50 salariés devront verser une part
d'intéressement ou de participation
supplémentaires écoutez maintenant le
secrétaire général de la CFDT quelques
œufs quelques heures avant la signature
de la Corse et sur France Info
53% je crois de mémoire enfin des
salariés ont un dispositif de
participation et d'intéressement dans
notre pays
83% dans les grandes entreprises 17% des
entreprises dans les petites entreprises
dans les entreprises de moins de 5 ans
aujourd'hui il y a quasiment il y a très
peu d'endroits où il y a de la
participation et d'intéressement vous
allez pas me faire croire que toutes les
entreprises au moins de 50 c'est une
entreprise sont pas profité voilà les
partenaires sociaux ont maintenant
jusqu'au 22 février pour définitivement
signer l'accord il faut dire qu'ils
étaient sous la pression du gouvernement
et du parti de la majorité qui entendait
mettre en place un système de dividendes
salariés le parti Renaissance a organisé
d'ailleurs une convention sur le sujet
le 20 février prochain merci beaucoup
Quentin on reparlera des supers profits
austral dernier chapitre de l'émission
Cécile Duflot mais cet accord voilà
est-ce qu'on peut dire que c'est un réel
progrès pour les salariés français du
privé je rappelle que ça concerne les
salariés français du privé
qu'en 2019 nous avions publié un rapport
sur la répartition justement des profits
créés qui avait donné lieu beaucoup de
critiques mais qui a contribué à faire
avancer le débat parce que la réalité
c'est qu'aujourd'hui une grosse partie
de ces dividendes de ces profits sont
reversés aux actionnaires et ça n'épuise
pas le débat de l'investissement parce
qu'il faut quand même se dire que dans
beaucoup d'entreprises on a pas été à la
hauteur en matière d'investissement pour
tenir une trajectoire et une vraie
trajectoire conforme aux accords de
Paris
moi aussi je considère que cet accord va
dans le bon sens parce qu'il corrige une
égalité manifeste entre des salariés des
grandes entreprises et ça les petites
entreprises maintenant il faudrait pas
aller trop loin dans cette direction
parce que la solution au fait que il y a
des supers profits chez Total ou chez
LVMH c'est pas des redistribués aux
salariés c'est de les socialiser
on revient aux dividendes sociétales
dont on parlait tout à l'heure on
revient aux dividendes sociétales on
revient à la question de la fiscalité on
revient un ensemble de questions on le
revient à des questions de concurrence
on peut pas considérer que les grandes
entreprises qui sont super profitables
vont s'exonérer de leur responsabilité
en partageant la rente avec leur salarié
à Nicolas Terry se dividende salarié
alors c'est le terme je sais pas si vous
le prenez c'est le vous le reprenez à
votre compte se termine ça existe déjà
c'est comment vous redistribuez la
valeur a d'abord à vos salariés en
entreprise d'abord un salarié c'est un
investissement dans une entreprise c'est
un formidable créateur de valeur et donc
il faut éviter bon et je crois en
contrat de travail je crois au contrat
de travail durant les déterminé on loue
sa force de travail on apporte toute sa
compétence et tout son développement et
effectivement au Crédit Mutuel on essaie
d'avoir une vision sur la totalité de la
carrière et donc bah oui par exemple en
2022 on a fait plus 6,3% d'augmentation
de salaire 3000 euros de prime Macron et
l'intéressement participation c'est
quasiment deux mois de salaire parce que
on a été très performant collectivement
et c'est normal mais avec une exigence
de faire mieux l'année prochaine et moi
je regarde dans les interrompre le fait
de vous créez un dividende sociétal donc
je rappelle donc redistribution 15 % de
2006 plutôt à des associations des
entreprises pour le bien commun qui
seront pas forcément rentables tout de
suite et puis des conditions on va dire
plus plus avantageuses pour les salariés
pour les clients en grande difficulté ça
ça se fait pas au détriment de la
redistribution des salariés parce que
c'est ce qu'on pourrait imaginer non et
c'est pour ça enfin pas que seulement
pour ça parce qu'ils aient assez de
bénéfices pour redistribuer des deux
côtés des deux côtés on en a fait un
calcul de dividendes salariés c'est
18,9% de nos résultats donc vous voyez
15% de dividendes sociétales 18,9 de
dividendes salariés donc on assume toute
la responsabilité et je trouve que
l'intervention à la fois de jouer au
froid ou de Béziers de Laurent Berger le
montre bien c'est que la démocratie
sociale ça peut fonctionner et ça peut
notamment donner une perspective parce
qu'on voit bien que ce qu'il cherche à
enclencher c'est une autre attitude un
autre comportement dans les toutes
petites entreprises et je trouve que
c'est une très belle leçon aujourd'hui
où on s'interroge sur les questions
sociales bah ça c'est de l'intelligence
collective
parce que on ne reste que le diagnostic
on adresse on donne une perspective et
un cap et on se donne le moyen de
l'atteindre Jean-Pierre vous êtes
d'accord pour dire que cet accord c'est
une sorte de de leçon en creux en plein
débat sur la réforme des retraites oui
j'ai pas la seule c'est-à-dire que
effectivement entre entre la manière
dont aujourd'hui les les Français sont
en train de se réconcilier avec le
syndicalisme et la distance qu'il prenne
avec le spectacle politique de
l'Assemblée c'est très impressionnant et
je pense que c'est lourd de conséquences
Cécile Duflot sur la je reste sur cette
idée de redistribution de de la richesse
aux salariés là aussi
est-ce qu'il y a un mouvement
généralisé ou est-ce que il y a
l'obligation que l'État soit plus
interventionniste pour que ça avance
vous l'avez dit vous même si il y a eu
cette négociation entre les syndicats de
salariés et le Medef c'est parce qu'il y
avait la de d'une décision législative
et que il fallait mieux qu'ils se
mettent d'accord sinon il y aurait eu
une bonne manière de favoriser la
discussion entre les syndicats mais en
tout cas ce qui est sûr c'est que je
pense que dans un certain nombre de cas
on a besoin de régulation collective
alors quelle nest de la discussion
partenariale entre les syndicats
auxquels naissent de l'encadrement
législatif c'est
en tout cas une bonne chose mais je
rejoins totalement ce qu'a dit Jean
pylani Ferri tout à l'heure sur la
question des profits et des super
profils mais plus des profits de façon
plus large sur le fait qu'ils doivent
être en partie et en large partie
investie dans la transition que pour une
part ils doivent revenir dans l'activité
de l'ensemble de la société être
socialisé oui et c'est normal et pour
une part revenir aux salariés c'est tout
à fait possible de réfléchir sous ces
trois axes là en sachant que aujourd'hui
les distributions dividendes aux
actionnaires ont été tellement folles
qu'elles ont eu lieu dans un tiers des
cas dans des entreprises qui ne
n'avaient pas de bén c'est à dire qu'on
allait puiser dans les réserves pour
distribuer des dividendes et cette
pression des actionnaires sur un certain
nombre d'entreprises qui empêchent des
stratégies de moyens long terme doit
être allégé je pense qu'on a une vraie
question qu'on voit bien paraître dans
notre départ d'alignement de tous les
acteurs et personnellement je trouve par
exemple que les rachats d'actions donc
un sens parce que notre expliqué ce que
c'est en cas de
je rends l'argent aux actionnaires
j'annule les actions correspondantes
comme si le rôle d'une entreprise
c'était de rendre l'argent aux
actionnaires avec son rôle c'est de
faire de l'investissement de créer de la
valeur collective et effectivement de le
faire de manière rentable et je pense
que pour remettre l'investissement au
cœur de l'entreprise il faut réaligner
les acteurs et pour ça ça veut dire que
la mission de l'entreprise c'est pas de
rendre de l'argent aux actionnaires
c'est d'investir et à soi même que le
président américain c'est positionnés
ça n'a pas de sens la deuxième chose
c'est que je pense aussi que comme
dirigeant il faudrait être rémunéré
qu'avec une rémunération fixe elle peut
être très élevée elle est souvent très
élevée mais je pense que tous les
mécanismes de rémunération variable
notamment indexée sur les valeurs des
actions sont terriblement
contre-productifs parce que diriger une
entreprise c'est assuré une synthèse
entre tous les horizons de temps tous
les impératifs sociaux économiques
financiers écologiques et que pour ça il
n'y a pas de meilleur méthode qu'une
rémunération fixe qui quelque part dit
aux dirigeants faites du mieux que vous
pouvez on va vous contrôler pour ça mais
on va pas tout indexer connaître le prix
de tout c'est de connaître la valeur de
rien et puis la troisième chose c'est
effectivement de généraliser le
dividende sociétale et je pense que si
on fait ce n'est pas la solution à tout
mais déjà trois mesures aussi simples
que celle là et bien on contribuera à
réaligner les entreprises avec
l'investissement alors sur les supers
profits je vais donner quelques chiffres
et ces bénéfices records en 2022 on a
parlé évidemment de Total énergie 19
milliards d'euros ça représente + 28%
par rapport à 2021 la BNP parida Paribas
10,2 milliards d'euros c'est plus sept
et demi LVMH 14 milliards d'euros c'est
plus 17% on pourrait rajouter l'armateur
CMA-CGM alors on n'a pas les chiffres
définitifs 2022 mais la fin du 3e
trimestre il y avait déjà 21,8 milliards
de dollars là de bénéfices soit 4
milliards de plus que pour 2021 un cours
toute l'année donc on peut imaginer ce
que ça va donner
Cécile Duflot vous avez un peu répandu à
la question mais comment mettre ses
entreprises à contribution c'est-à-dire
super profit contribution exceptionnelle
d'abord taxation des profits il faut
quand même c'est Estaires du flow qui le
dit il faut élargir le débat sur la
taxation des profits réfléchir une
taxation progressive la même manière que
vous l'avez sur les revenus mais ce qui
est certain c'est que les super profits
de l'année dernière d'ailleurs et de
cette année aurait dû faire l'objet
d'une super taxation pour une raison
très simple ils sont d'ailleurs en
anglais on dit pas des supers profits on
dit des winfo le profit ça veut dire des
profits tombés du ciel parce
qu'effectivement c'est de l'argent qui a
été gagné du fait de la crise et
notamment du fait d'un soutien public
LVMH double c'est profit c'est pas parce
qu'ils vont deux fois plus de sacs à
main c'est parce que il y a eu un
soutien publique massif avec du chômage
partiel dans toutes les boutiques
Sephora parce qu'il y a eu une politique
massive de rachat d'actifs au niveau
européen et que ça éviter une crise
économique comme on a pu connaître en
2008 et je dis c'était une très bonne
chose ça a été un bon choix de politique
publique de soutenir l'économie mais une
fois donc retour de balancier maintenant
et ça se fait dans d'autres pays
l'Espagne et d'ailleurs des taxes sont
les super profits même Margaret Thatcher
en son temps on avait fait parce que
c'est la logique enfin c'est absurde
d'imaginer que ces profits vont être
uniquement distribués en dividende aux
actionnaires ce qui contribue d'ailleurs
à accroître les inégalités de manière
considérable et qui dans un moment où la
société est percutée par les inégalités
et par les conséquences de la crise
climatique créer une situation de
tension sociale extrêmement forte qu'on
voit au travers du débat sur les
retraites mais qui sinon naîtra à une
autre occasion il faut être très
conscient que si on fait pas payer le
prix de cette facture de la crise si on
fait pardon payer le prix de cette
facture de la crise ou à l'ensemble des
ménages et qu'on laisse c'est super
profits dans la nature et auprès des
actionnaires là on aura une fracture qui
va être de plus en plus profonde dans la
société quand on parle de super profit
au patron de Total énergie il répond il
y a eu des investissements il y a eu des
choix stratégiques Jean Pisani ferry ce
terme-là de super profit il a une enfin
il a il a un sens économique vous voyez
ce que je veux dire je sais que Bruno Le
Maire a dit qu'il ne savait pas ce que
c'était je pense que la rente on sait ce
que c'est et effectivement il y a des
profits qui à un moment sont exactement
ce que ce que vous dites c'est windfall
ça tombe du ciel ça tombe du ciel ça
tombe du ciel parce que on est dans une
situation qui est très peu
concurrentielle et là à ce moment-là la
réponse c'est la concurrence ça tombe du
ciel parce que on a les regardez CMA CGM
vous prenez cet exemple pourquoi ils
font des profits parce que le prix du
fret de leur métier le prix du fret a
augmenté de manière astronomique bon
c'est temporaire d'ailleurs c'est parce
que c'est en train de Noël normalisé
mais il y a une question quand même
pourquoi est-ce que effectivement
ce profit exceptionnel qu'ils ont fait
qui ne qui n'est pas dû à une activité
particulièrement innovante ou quoi que
ce soit c'est une prof qui est tombé du
sujet pourquoi est-ce que on considère
que il est il est de bonne pratique de
leur laisser la totalité de ce profit
donc je pense qu'il y a des il y a des
vraies questions là-dessus et et il faut
il faut trouver des réponses et d'autant
plus que c'est un point sur lequel je
voulais revenir tout ce qu'on disait sur
le coup de la transition
écologique il y en a une partie qui va
devoir être prise en charge par l'État
c'est à dire tout ce qui est l'aide à la
rénovation des logements des passeurs
thermiques des ménages qui n'ont pas
d'accès au crédit même le Crédit Mutuel
dans un certain nombre de cas ne peut
pas faire crédit à ces ménages il peut
pas
payer le coût pour les artisans du
remplacement de leur fourgonnette donc
il y a tout ça il va falloir le
socialiser et c'est ça va être un coût
important donc il y a il y a un sujet de
finance publique qui va être posé qui
est posée et sur lequel il faut trouver
des réponses alors c'est super profit
certain veulent les consacrer à financer
nos retraites c'est ce que propose par
exemple cette porte-parole d'une
association
écologiste l'association Alternative
sur le financement du système de
retraite on cherche de l'argent on se
pose la question que vous pouvez
l'argent alors que l'argent il est là il
est exactement chez Total qui donne
super profit sont pas du tout accès à la
hauteur qui serait l'être donc total
s'enrichit vraiment sur sur le des gens
en pleine crise énergétique
Émilie côté politique chez les élus on
fait aussi ce lien oui le lien entre les
super profits et la réforme des
retraites il est vite fait on le voit
sur un tweet de Sandrine Rousseau qui a
souvent député ELV qui a souvent des
tweets très explicites en tout cas elle
fait le lien entre le bénéfice record de
Total énergie annoncé en janvier donc
total à verser 13 milliards d'euros de
dividendes le déficit maximal du système
de retraite sera de 12 milliards d'euros
bonne journée donc à bonne entendeur on
comprend très bien le message alors il
faut dire que ce sujet des supers
profits il fait débat depuis plusieurs
mois depuis quasiment le début de la
nouvelle législature au milieu de
l'assemblée nationale sans qu'il y ait
de réelles avancées vous l'avez dit un
Bruno Le Maire il veut pas trop en
entendre même si son président avait
parlé de profiteur de guerre quand même
ça a été préféré une taxe européenne
sur les énergéticiens sur les super
profits qui avaient été faits donc ça a
été adopté en 2022 et puis il y a eu
aussi la ristourne ponctuelle de Total
énergie on s'en souvient c'était sur le
prix des carburants en septembre l'État
est en train de demander une deuxième
peut-être histoire qui sera acceptée par
tout à l'énergie mais pas de tactation
plus durable ou plus globale sur les
super profits c'est le parti socialiste
notamment qui a décidé de relancer le
sujet oui alors au sein du Parti
socialiste évidemment le sujet fait
l'unanimité c'est ce qu'a souligné son
premier secrétaire fraîchement réélu
Olivier Faure lors du congrès du PS fin
janvier
et les villes évidentes roule sous nos
yeux là haut ces bonbons mais ça serait
injuste à leurs yeux de ponctionner ceux
qui ont déjà tout leur seul courage
c'est de s'attaquer aux gens ordinaires
jamais contre les puissances de l'argent
alors pour celles et ceux qui aspirent
au repos et aspire à vivre mieux nous
serons dans rue mardi prochain
alors le PS avait choisi de porter le
sujet dans une proposition de loi dans
le cadre de leur niche parlementaire qui
aurait été discuté le 9 février dernier
mais finalement ils ont considéré qu'il
y avait peu de chance pour que cette
proposition de loi soit adoptée et ils
ont décidé de retirer le texte au profit
d'un amendement sur le texte justement
qui traite de la réforme des retraites
le fameux projet de loi finance de
finance rectif de la sécurité sociale le
PLF RSS donc cet amendement il propose
donc de taxer les superfro offices c'est
vraiment indiqué comme ça des grandes
entreprises faisant plus de 750 millions
d'euros de chiffre d'affaires et le
produit irait au financement de la
branche retraite de la sécurité sociale
et donc il s'agit évidemment de trouver
des financements pour sauvegarder notre
système de retraite puisque l'idée donc
du PS à travers cette amendement c'est
trouver via la taxation des super
profits un moyen de financer notre
système de retraite sans avoir
évidemment à reculer l'âge légal du
départ à la retraite puisque le GPS y
est opposé plus globalement la nuit PSI
est opposée est plus globalement la
majorité des Français y est opposé
également on reste que l'amendement a
peu de chance d'être discuté parce que
la nuit pêche a décidé hier de retirer à
peu près 1000 amendements pour qu'on
aille plus vite sur la discussion du
qu'on aille jusqu'à l'article 7 et qu'on
aille jusqu'à l'article sec du départ de
l'âge de la retraite et surtout les
discussions sont terminées vendredi
prochain vendredi soir donc il y a peu
de chances qu'on arrive jusqu'à la
discussion de cet amendement et
finalement cette discussion qu'on a eu
aussi sur les super profits qui est
présente au sein de l'Assemblée
nationale mais au sein de la société et
des entreprises et des banques ils
risquent de passer encore une fois à la
trappe Nicolas Terry vous l'avez dit
publiquement vous n'êtes pas favorable à
cette à cette réforme des retraites
est-ce que qu'est-ce que vous pensez de
cette proposition de financement de nos
de notre système de par le par les super
profits
je pense en tout cas la contribution des
entreprises peut faire partie du débat
et je pense que aujourd'hui on a
vraiment d'intelligence collective
c'est-à-dire que je le prends de
positivement mais il y a beaucoup de
choses qui s'expriment notamment dans le
dans le débat social et on voit que par
exemple important de l'emploi des
seniors qui peut changer aussi les
équilibres apparaît fortement
l'importance de la formation
professionnelle toute la fille
l'important c'est effectivement de
l'égalité salariale et sociale la
nécessité aussi de conclure un vrai
contrat entre les générations de prendre
en compte la pénibilité et je trouve que
tous les ingrédients d'une très belle
réforme sont là et que on est dans un
moment très responsable très clair où
les notions de justice d'équilibre de
projection des projets de vie peut
apparaître donc moi mon seul souhait
c'est qu'on soit l'écoute de ce moment
là je voudrais juste donner une petite
anecdote le Crédit Mutuel embauche 1300
apprentis par an
[Musique]
du territoire français puisque français
ne peut pas simplement les approprier
deuxièmement je pense que pour les
retraites on a besoin de ressources
pérennes et je suis pas sûr que les
super profits pour toutes les raisons
qu'on a indiqué sur les ressources
pérennes et troisièmement je pense qu'un
bon équilibre du système de retraite
c'est un système qui reste contributif
c'est-à-dire que c'est assis quand même
sur de la cotisation c'est pas assis sur
la recette fiscale donc pour toutes ces
raisons je suis pas très favorable à
cette mesure il nous reste un peu plus
de deux minutes je vais je vais de
nouveau sortir un peu de du débat de
cette question de la retraite pour
élargir un peu avec une dernière
question Cécile Duflot et je vais donner
l'exemple de BNP Paribas on a cité les
les bénéfices records de BNP Paribas sur
le rôle politique et sociétal d'une
entreprise c'est une entreprise doivent
peut-être choisir son camp voilà ce qui
se passe pour BNP Paribas vous vous
critiquez BNP Paribas chez Oxfam pour
notamment les investissements dans les
projets fossiles les nouveaux projets
fossiles etc au même moment qui sont
boycotés par l'État du Texas parce
qu'ils sont dans une liste d'une dizaine
de d'incides-sions financières ils sont
jugés trop verts
oui mais non mais c'est intéressant
parce que donc ils sont entre le marteau
et l'enclume une certaine façon donc il
faut choisir son camp à ce moment-là le
changement climatique versus l'État du
Texas c'est le changement climatique moi
je suis d'accord avec vous mais c'est
voilà une question c'est la neutralité
entre guillemets politiques d'entreprise
sur lesquels on peut avoir un débat
politique est-ce que c'est mieux de plus
ou moins partager les richesses ça on
peut avoir un débat politique très large
est-ce que c'est bien ou pas de faire
des efforts pour essayer de lutter
contre le changement climatique en fait
c'est pas une question de choix c'est là
maintenant c'est une question de science
donc d'être à la hauteur de l'enjeu
climatique c'est une question qui va
devenir une question vitale et je sais
bien que c'est l'argument favori de la
BNP mais aujourd'hui ils ont une
responsabilité qui est énorme c'est la
plus grosse banque européenne c'est là
le principal financeur des nouveaux
projets fossiles en Europe je vais dire
ils ont une grande grande marge avant de
devenir très vert et je crois
fondamentalement que cette obligation
elle pèse tout le monde est-ce que le
virage va pas être beaucoup plus rapide
c'est possible si il nous arrive deux ou
trois catastrophes comme celle qu'on a
vécu avec les mégafeux en Europe comme
une énorme tornade vous verrez que tout
ça ira très très vite et toutes ces
entreprises qui détiennent des actifs
carbointifs elles seront ruinées comme
il y a eu des grandes catastrophes
précédentes donc je oui un mot sur la
nécessité de le faire qui est une
nécessité vitale une nécessité pour
l'humanité et je le redis si on ne le
fait pas si on le fait c'est difficile
si on le fait pas non seulement ça
coûtera beaucoup plus cher mais ce sera
beaucoup plus violent merci beaucoup
merci à tous d'avoir participé à ce
débat je vous dis à demain pour un
nouveau numéro de sens public et puis
votre prochain rendez-vous politique
dans la matinale Oriane Mancini reçoit
le porte-parole du rassemblement
national Sébastien Chenu bonne soirée